بعد ان كان مقررا تسليمها لاوكرانيا بحلول
عام 2024 الولايات المتحده تسرع وتيره
تسليم دبابات ابرز الى اوكرانيا بحلول
خريف هذا العام واشنطن اكدت ان وتيره
التسليم السريعه ستسمح لاوكرانيا بالدفاع
عن نفسها
درسنا العديد من الخيارات لتسليم المدرعات
باسرع وتيره وبالتنسيق الوثيق
اتخذت قرارا بتوفير دبابات ابرامز من طراز
بدلا من اموان ايتو هذا سيمكننا من تعجيل
مواعيد التسليم بشكل كبير
وكانت الولايات المتحده قد تعهدت في يناير
كانون الثاني بامداد اوكرانيا ب 31
الدبابه ابرز بعد رفض فكره نشر الدبابات
هناك على مدى شهور
اداره الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن اكدت انها
ستسلم ايضا منظومات الدفاع الجوي باتري
وفق جدول زمنيه اسرع مما كان متوقعا
الولايات المتحده اكدت ان اوكرانيا دربت
جهودها بسرعه اكبر لتلقي هذه المعدات في
اسرع وقت